In the last video,
we saw that if we
were to take the sum from i
equals 0 to n of i squared,
that this could be equal to--
and we did it in two videos.
It was a little bit hairy,
but we powered through.
This is equal to 1/3
n to the third power.
Let me write it a little
cleaner than that.
n to the third power plus
1/2 n squared plus 1/6 n.
And that is absolutely
true, but you
might have seen a
different formula
for this that doesn't
look like that.
And so what I want to do is now
manipulate this a little bit
algebraically to come up
with another formula that's
typically seen for this sum.
So the first thing
that we might realize
is, well, what happens
if we factor out a 1/6 n?
So this is going to
be equal to-- let's
factor out this right over here.
So that would be equal to
1/6 n times-- so let's see.
1/3 divided by 1/6, that's
the same thing as 1/3 times 6.
So this right over here is going
to be equal to 2 n squared.
And you can verify it.
1/6 times 2 is 2/6 or 1/3.
n times n squared is
n to the third power.
Now, 1/2 divided by
1/6 is the same thing
as 1/2 times 6, which is 3.
So this term right over here
is going to be plus 3 times n.
And then finally, you
have this term right
over here, which is just
going to be equal to 1.
And now we're faced with
factoring this thing
right over here.
Now, you could to do
this-- well, let's factor
by grouping this.
And remember, when you
factor by grouping,
you want to
essentially break this
into two numbers where the
product of those two numbers
is equal to the
product of 2 times 1.
And the obvious thing
is, well, 2 times 1 is 2.
If I break this into 2 and 1,
if I break this 3 into 2 and 1,
well, 2 times 1 is
definitely 2 times 1.
So let me rewrite this.
I'm just factoring by grouping
here, nothing super fancy.
So if I rewrite this as 2 n
squared plus n plus 2n plus 1--
so this is all the stuff
in this parentheses
right over here-- well,
this part right over here
we can factor out an n.
So this is going to be equal
to-- let me just write the 1/6
n here so you know
what I'm doing.
So if we factor out
an n right over here,
we would have n times 2n plus 1.
So that's what's in
green right over here.
That's this part
right over here.
And then what I have
here, I could write this
as plus 1 times 2n plus 1.
Let me do it in that same
color, so 1 times 2n plus 1.
And so now, you can
factor out a 2n plus 1.
And this thing simplifies
to 1/6 n times 2n plus 1.
I'm just factoring
out a 2n plus 1.
And then if you factor a 2n plus
1 out of each of these terms,
you're going to
just an n and a 1.
So 1/6 times n times 2n
plus 1 times n plus 1.
And if this was a little bit
confusing what I did here,
I encourage you to
review the videos
on factoring by grouping.
And another way we
can rewrite this,
we could write this whole
thing as being equal to--
and maybe I'll write
it in this green color
that we started off with.
This is the same
thing as-- and I'll
write it as n times
n plus 1 times 2n
plus 1, all of that over 6.
So this expression is
equivalent to this expression,
and it's equivalent
to this value
right over here, so
whichever one you
find to be a little bit
easier to think about.